the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome to the metabolism portion of
biological chemistry 507 my name is
Johnny Sigmund and I teach this course
with Joann stubby I'm primarily a
chalkboard teacher as you'll notice from
my notes in order to make things as
simple as possible I use a lot of
abbreviations in my abbreviations list
will be appended elsewhere let's start
by looking at a metabolic chart figure
16 - 1 from the textbook obviously it
looks very complex part of the challenge
of both teaching and learning
biochemistry is finding a way to look at
this pigs breakfast of biochemical
reactions and find its underlying
structure for the purpose of this course
the underlying structure we're going to
look for is the biochemical pathways
that let us function for example a
pathway could involve making ATP or it
could be putting an amino group onto an
alpha keto acid in order to make an
amino acid although a few people think
of biochemistry is simple formatting the
pigs breakfast into pathways that have
functional meaning helps us simplify
them and make them easier to remember
the second simplifying point is that all
biochemical pathways are reversible the
gray vertical bar in the middle of this
figure is the biochemical pathway of
glycolysis going from glucose to
pyruvate there are 10 steps some of
these steps have a negative Delta G that
is they are favorable in the direction
drawn and some of them have a positive
Delta G that is those steps are
favorable in the opposite direction but
overall when you sum them up all of the
free energies of the glycolytic pathway
you get a negative number which means
that the pathway of glycolysis is
overall thermodynamically irreversible
and progresses from glucose to pyruvate
it turns out that there's another
pathway called gluconeogenesis that
pathway it involves taking non
carbohydrate precursors such as pyruvate
that's just one example
kill and converting that precursor to
glucose in other words gluconeogenesis
in effect is the reverse of glycolysis
as I said the pathway going from glucose
down to pyruvate is exergonic so what
about the pathway from pyruvate up to
glucose in order to make the pathway go
from pyruvate to glucose what nature did
was invent several biochemical steps
that are highly exergonic that is what
we'll see is they're going to require
ATP or some other form of energy input
in order to make the entire pathway of
gluconeogenesis exergonic exergonic as
is required of all pathways so we can
indeed convert pyruvate to glucose but
it will require energy input to make the
pathway of gluconeogenesis have a net
negative Delta G that is be favorable
the third thing that actually makes
biochemistry tractable is the fact that
nature uses only a very limited
repertoire of chemical reactions
Joanne showed us that despite the
complexity of this overall metabolic
chart there are only about nine or ten
discrete chemical reactions that nature
uses so at any given step for example in
glycolysis you really only have about
nine or ten options and of that nine or
ten only about one or two perhaps three
would be chemically reasonable if you
know your organic chemistry and these
nine or ten reaction types you should be
able to navigate the biochemical chart
with comparative ease the fourth point I
wanted to make is perhaps one of the
most important is that all biochemical
pathways are regulated chaos would
result for example if you made glucose
and at the same time took that molecule
of glucose and degraded it that's an
example of what we call a futile cycle
sometimes util cycles can be beneficial
to a cell for example that could be a
way of generating heat but most of the
time we want to avoid them because we
usually want to avoid futile cycles
nature uses pathway regulation to avoid
them to provide directionality to
pathways what nature does is work
thermodynamically irreversible steps
into the front end and back end of the
pathway sometimes nature puts in an
irreversible step in the middle of the
pathway
if that pathway has a branch point that
happens with glycolysis cells will see
sometimes regulation is affected by
putting covalent functionalities such as
a phosphate onto an amino acid on a
protein that modification could increase
or decrease the biochemical activity of
that protein often a phosphorylated
protein is highly active turning on a
pathway and it is DS phosphorylated when
the pathway needs to be turned off a
second way to regulate a step in the
pathway is by allosteric regulation of
the enzymes of the pathway in that case
a small molecule will interact with the
enzyme in order to increase or decrease
its activity Joanne taught us about
Alice Terry when she taught us how
hemoglobin is regulated to reiterate
nature uses these regulatable enzymes at
key places in overall metabolic pathways
to enable us to be able to achieve the
function of the pathway without wasting
energy or resources the last
introductory point I want to make is
that all biochemical pathways tend to be
compartmentalized at least in mammalian
cells although it's increasingly
becoming obvious that even in bacteria
there is some form of
compartmentalization that is clustering
of enzymes for a particular pathway in a
particular area of the cell for example
in a mammalian cell the mitochondrion is
the site of fatty acid beta oxidation or
breakdown the tricarboxylic acid cycle
and enzymes of the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex are also
mitochondrial the cytoplasm is the site
where we do fatty acid biosynthesis most
of gluconeogenesis glycolysis and the
pentose phosphate pathway
compartmentalization helps keep the
metabolic chart tidy and organized with
that in the way of an introduction let's
turn to my lecture notes which i present
in the format of storyboards in the
first storyboard panel a I give the
definition of metabolism as the linked
set of biochemical reactions by which we
obtain and use free energy that is Delta
G for life we use that free energy for a
lot of things but the use is really
divided into three areas the first is to
do mechanical work the second is to
generate concentration gradients and the
third
is for biosynthesis in a few minutes I'm
going to be giving you an example of all
three panel B biochemists divide
metabolism to two subcategories
catabolism and anabolism briefly
catabolism consists of the energy
yielding pathways an analysis basically
biosynthesis we use the free energy that
we generate through catabolism in order
to assemble complex molecules by way of
an Abba lism let's look at panel C we're
going to start 5:07 with the discussion
of catabolism that is the energy
yielding pathways by way of definitions
a reduced molecule is one that is
abundantly supplied with electrons
examples are carbohydrates fats and
proteins these are typically our foods
the process of catabolism involves
finding a way to liberate the electrons
from those reduced substances and
transfer those electrons to mobile
electron carriers such as nad plus to
form NADH or nadp+ to form NADPH the
process by which electrons are removed
from a molecule is called oxidation and
the oxidation products are for example
carbon dioxide that we breathe out or in
some organisms lactate or other simple
molecules that are excreted simple that
is compared to the complex reduced
molecules that we consume as food nadh
and fadh2 molecules that Joanne taught
us are what I'll refer to as mobile
electron carriers they can usually move
around inside the cell although
sometimes they're embedded within
enzymes that is usually the case with
fadh2 we consume an enormous lee large
number of reduced substances due to the
complexities of our diets and catabolism
revolves taking the electrons out of
this enormous leave ass array of
substrates and transferring those
electrons to a small number of reduced
electron carriers for example an ad or
Flavin's in the process of respiration
which we'll come to later the electrons
are further transferred from the reduced
electron carriers all the way to
molecular oxygen the reduction of
molecular oxygen is a highly exothermic
reaction we're going to be able to use
the energy that's generated by
oxygen reduction in order to make ATP
and to do some other important
biochemical activities now I'm going to
introduce a physiological scenario and
use it in order to introduce the pathway
of glycolysis in class at this point I
usually ask a student to stand up and
sit down as you can imagine being called
out in class creates more than a little
bit of anxiety in the student let's look
at panel D the signal to stand up and
sit down is processed by the brain and
an electrical signal then goes by the
nerves to the muscles enabling the
student to stand up the anxiety of being
called on by the teacher in class
results in a nervous excitation of the
adrenal gland specifically in the
andrina medulla which releases
epinephrine epinephrine is also known as
adrenaline it goes to the muscles as
well as other organs of the body as
we'll see later in 507 and the
epinephrine will interact at cell
membranes by way of transmembrane
receptors in order to turn on pathways
of catabolism in order to generate the
ATP that's needed to help the student
deal with this stressful situation this
is sometimes called the fight-or-flight
response at this point in the class if I
really wanted to make my point and have
it transferred to every student
I'd announce a pop quiz the announcement
of a pop quiz would cause kind of this
cold feeling throughout your gut that's
actually the feeling of adrenaline
preparing your body to deal with the
stress situation in that case of the
quiz let's look at panel II as a
scenario progresses let me introduce a
few biochemical players glycogen
phosphorylase glucose glucose
6-phosphate and glucose 1-phosphate
in panel F we see a muscle cell the
epinephrine in the blood is only going
to reach a concentration of about 10 to
the minus 10 molar that's a very very
low concentration the epinephrine is
going to interact at the beta and alpha
adrenergic receptors in the muscle cell
membrane this interaction results in the
activation of a kinase that is a
molecule that transfers a phosphate
group and that kinase which is called SP
k4
days phosphorylase kinase phosphorylates
serine 14 on glycogen phosphorylase
phosphorylation activates glycogen
phosphorylase which will then begin to
degrade glycogen the polymeric storage
form of glucose in us that is mammals to
produce initially glucose 1-phosphate
glucose 1-phosphate will then go through
a number of transformations and
eventually be converted into other forms
of glucose and then other molecules that
will generate energy in nutshell this
stand up sit down scenario results in
the generation of energy in a matter of
seconds which is one of the things that
we use metabolism for another thing i
said earlier was that you use metabolic
energy to generate concentration
gradients and it turns out that
generation of concentration gradients is
absolutely critical for muscle activity
the sarcoplasmic reticulum in our muscle
cells must accumulate calcium and
release it at precisely defined moments
in order to enable the muscle to be able
to work that concentration gradient of
calcium has to be created and it's
created with the energy that we get from
metabolism again we'll see how calcium
gradients help boot up energy generation
in the last lecture which deals with
pathway regulation